c'est pendant la fin de semaine de
pâques qu'on brasse les meilleures
affaires dans les chocolateries et pour
certains clients pas question de se
restreindre quand vient le temps de se
sucrer le bec je me suis raté j'ai gardé
ma famille je me le permettre parce que
si bon et c'est une batterie pour tout
le monde oui la franchise en échec j'ai
toujours acheté
pour 30 m de dollars mais ça vaut la
peine et oui même les animaux en
chocolat sont victimes de l'inflation
bien d'autres choses le prix des
pastilles de cacao a bondi ca a augmenté
d'environ 7% dans l'année c'est quand
même énorme puis je dirais que c'est pas
le seul défi parce que tout ce qui est
approvisionnement non seulement chocolat
mais tout ce qui est en bas âge c'est
vrai qu'en style des fois ya des
pénuries tio vous avez autre chose on à
faire depuis deux ans et dit bédard hadj
augmenter ses prix pour une première
fois
j'ai pas eu le choix j'avais pas
augmenté depuis le début de l'ouverture
puis
si le faisait pas j'allais me faire
rentrer dedans donc on fait ce qu'il
faut et puis on espère que les clients
soient
dans ce magasin de friandises qui a
pignon sur rue depuis 1929 on s'attend à
recevoir jusqu'à 1000 clients par jour
cours de la fin de semaine c'est
définitivement la plus grosse paire de
l'année pour nous autres on est vraiment
les grandes spécialités chocolats de
pâques mais puisque les fournisseurs ont
aussi leurs prix la boutique a dû
ajuster les siennes en conséquence on
via le prend 1 6% en augmentation cette
année 5 6% malgré tout juliet 6 mars à
temps réalisé de bonnes ventes des
jambes ressortiront les voient leurs
familles vont se rencontrer vont se
rassembler donc c'est plus propre et à
offrir et il y a du choix pour ceux qui
veulent épater la galerie c'est le plus
gros lapin qu'on a ici 4 points 2 kg
environ quatre pieds de hauteur ils se
détaillent 109 99 donc c'est une bonne
famille c'est parfait pour partager avis
aux intéressés c'est le dernier qui
restent tous les autres ont déjà été
vendus ici olivier bachand radio canada
montréal